What Napoleon had to do with the Invention
of Margarine
Odds are you probably have a stick or a tub
of it sitting in your fridge right now, but
do you have any idea how margarine became
a staple in most kitchens?
It turns out, margarine has a long and controversial
international history, and can even boast
the involvement of Emperor Napoleon III in
its invention.
Margarine derives its name from a discovery
in a chemist’s lab in France in 1813.
Scientist Michel Eugène Chevreul uncovered
a new fatty acid that he decided to call “acide
margarique.”
His discovery consisted of shiny, pearl-like
deposits, so margarites seemed an apt name,
as it is the Greek word for “pearly.”
Several decades later, Napoleon III was pondering
the fact that not only the poor people in
his empire, but also his armed forces, could
certainly use an affordable substitute for
butter; so he offered a reward to anyone clever
enough to come up with a suitable, cheap replacement.
A chemist named Hippolyte Mège-Mouriès rose
to the occasion, inventing a substance he
dubbed “oleomargarine,” which was later
shortened to “margarine.”
By 1869, Mège-Mouriès had patented the process
for creating margarine that had won him Napoleon’s
prize.
His oleomargarine was comprised primarily
of beef tallow, salt, sulfate of soda, gastric
juices of a pig, and a little cream, all heated
and mixed into a butter-like substance, though
in truth at this stage it was more of a jelly
than what we think of as margarine today…
but it kind of tasted like butter at least!
Despite winning the prize, the product never
really took off.
Mège-Mouriès sold the patent to a Dutch
outfit called Jurgens in 1871, which spawned
Unilever, still the leading manufacturer of
margarine to this day.
This company improved upon Mège-Mouriès’
techniques and created an international market
for margarine, building factories in Germany,
Norway, Austria, Sweden, Denmark, Norway and
England.
The Dutch businessmen also realized that if
they were hoping to sell their product as
a butter substitute, it would be helpful for
margarine to look as much like butter as possible.
Besides improvements in texture, they also
had to fix the color.
You see, margarine is naturally white; thus,
they began dyeing it slightly yellow to match
the faint yellowish tinge butter naturally
has.
(Of course, today many butter makers also
dye their butter to make it a much deeper
yellow than is natural, as this is what people
have come to expect.)
The war between butter and margarine had begun.
As Mark Twain recorded overhearing from a
businessman around the turn of the century
on a riverboat trip in Cincinnati:
“Why, we are turning out oleomargarine now,
by the thousands of tons.
And we can sell it so dirt-cheap that the
whole country has got to take it-can’t get
around it, you see.
Butter don’t stand any show-there ain’t
any chance for competition.”
This particular businessman didn’t take
into account dirty politics.
After buttering up various politicians, the
dairy industry convinced them to pass The
Margarine Act of 1886, which put a two cent
tax (about 50 cents today) on every pound
of margarine sold.
Within two decades, that was raised to ten
cents per pound (about $2.61 today).
(In Canada, the situation was much more serious
for margarine fans – margarine was made
illegal from 1886 to 1948.)
Around this same time, particularly in U.S.
states where the dairy industry held great
sway, dying margarine yellow became illegal
to further discourage sales and keep people
hooked on butter.
In a few states, it even became law that margarine
sold in those states had to be dyed pink.
Nefarious advertisements were also run, such
as one in a 1911 edition of the Chicago Tribune
where it showed arsenic, tin cans, and cats
being thrown into a vat with a few other ingredients
where it was all mixed together to form margarine.
Various rumors were spread about as to what
went into making margarine, even though essentially
margarine and butter weren’t all that different
at this point, with both containing about
80% animal fat and 20% water.
The fats involved here were even predominately
from the same dairy animal.
However, the popular main type of fat used
in margarine was about to change.
The lack of available beef fat, coupled with
new techniques in the hydrogenation of plant
materials, made the use of vegetable oils
in the formulation of margarine not only possible
for the first time, but much more economically
viable.
Between 1900 and 1920, oleomargarine was made
with a mixture of animal fats and vegetable
oils.
The Great Depression, followed by rationing
during World War II, led to a further reduction
in the supply of animal fat, and by the mid-40s,
the original margarine had almost disappeared
from grocer’s shelves in favor of the vegetable
oil version.
These events, particularly WWII, also helped
spur the popularity of margarine as butter
shortages abounded.
By 1950, this surge in popularity resulted
in the old extreme tax on margarine predominately
going away, for the first time since the beginning
putting margarine on a level playing field
with butter.
There still was the coloring issue for a few
years longer.
From the beginning, the margarine manufacturers
retaliated by packaging their product complete
with a packet of yellow dye included.
The intent was for the margarine to be placed
in a bowl and mixed with a spoon by the consumer.
The down-side to this was that the final results
were often uneven, and could end up as light
or dark yellow, or even yellow and white striped.
Another method of dyeing the margarine entailed
placing a capsule inside a plastic package
of margarine.
The package was then kneaded to distribute
the dye, a job usually given to one of the
lucky children of the household.
In the mid-1950s, like the heavy taxation
that was removed a few years before, the artificial
coloring laws were done away with and margarine
could be sold in pretty butter-like hues once
again.
Since then, many efforts have been made to
progressively make margarine more healthy,
such as introducing healthier fats and nixing
the trans-fats that used to be prevalent in
the substance.
There have also been improvements in flavor
to get things even more butter-like.
So, while the modern versions bear little
resemblance to the original oleomargarine,
other than usually containing approximately
the same amount of fats and water, we still
call it margarine.
Oh, and if you’re wondering what became
of Hippolyte Mège-Mouriès…
Aside from the prize he won from Emperor Napoleon
III, he didn’t really profit from his invention;
the poor guy died, well, poor in 1880.
Easy come, easy go.